in this app we see an example of a
defragmented network traffic that uses
the big cookie model all the repeating
transfers have been bundled together and
all of the intermittent transfers have
been largely replaced with aggressive
prefetching obviously you usually can't
entirely predict what data users might
need nor can you ignore either client or
server side changes that need to be
synchronized you can aim to minimize the
number of radio state transitions
through a combination of aggressive
prefetching in addition to bashing and
queuing any transfers that aren't time
critical and bundling these with user
initiated time-critical transfers or
those initiated from the server if we
compare the impact on the radio of the
big cookie model compared to the
previous on-demand approach you can see
it's now idle nearly two-thirds of the
time even the active radio percentage
has significantly dropped thanks to
improve download efficiency as a result
of transmitting more data in one shot